the prime minister to concede uh that
there was uh
rule-breaking law breaking uh and that
he bears some responsibility for the
culture uh of what was going on in
downing street through 2020 and 2021. um
boris johnson uh you can see uh up there
uh i think keen not to give a full
account of what went on until after sue
gray uh the independent official uh
makes clear uh what's in her final
for the report approach she's taken
throughout this distress energy care at
shrewsbury and telford hospital's nhs
trust
every woman giving birth has the right
to a safe birth and my heart therefore
goes out to the families for the
distress and uh suffering that they've
endured
my right honourable friend the secretary
of state for health will be making an
oral statement this afternoon setting
out the government's response mr speaker
this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
thank you mr speaker while our focus is
rightly on ukraine the prime minister
will be aware of the great concern many
people have across the baltic states so
can he outline the role the joint
expeditionary force can play in
countering russian aggression and
improving defensive posture for our
allies in the baltics yeah yeah prime
minister i thank him very much and the
the joint expeditionary force or the
jeff is a is an increasingly important
to grouping of the uh nordic countries
the baltic countries uh the dutch and
and ourselves who are committed to
working together in an active way
to counter russian
aggression and to support our ukrainian
friends and we had a very successful
meeting
a couple of weeks ago and we'll have
further such meetings in the course of
the next few weeks we now come to the
leader of the opposition kirsten
uh thank you mr speaker can i start by
joining the prime minister in his
remarks in relation to the honourable
member for bridgend
does the prime minister still think
that he and the chancellor are
tax-cutting conservatives
yes mr speaker i certainly i certainly
do because i certainly do because
uh this is uh this is the government uh
that has just introduced not only uh the
biggest cut in in fuel duty uh ever
uh but the the biggest uh the biggest
cut for in tax for working people in the
last 10 years uh mr speaker uh 70
of the uh of the of the population
paying uh national insurance
contribution will have a substantial tax
cut as a result of what uh the
chancellor did and if you take tickets
oh yeah well they don't like it it's
true they always put up taxes
[Applause]
they love it they love putting up taxes
uh but if you take together what we're
doing with income tax and national
insurance it's the biggest tax cut
proposed by my uh right on the fender
chancellor for 25 years
yes
cut the nonsense
[Applause]
and and treat the british people with a
bit of respect yeah
let me take him through this slowly
15 15 tax rises the highest tax burden
for 70 years
for every six pounds they're taking in
tax rises they're only handing one pound
back
prime minister is that cutting taxes or
is that raising taxes
mr speaker i don't know where he's been
for the last two years uh
but even even by the even by the
standards
even by the standards of even by the yes
he has
even by the standards of captain
hindsight mr speaker
to obliterate to obliterate the biggest
pandemic uh for the last century from
his memory to obliterate the 408 billion
that we've had to spend to look after
people up and down the country is quite
extraordinary and this is a government
that is getting on uh with reducing the
tax burden wherever we can what we are
doing mr speaker there's one there's one
there's one measure i think he should be
supporting and that's the health and
care levy mr speaker to fund our nhs
that's the one they oppose mr speaker
every other every other tax rise they're
all in favor of
[Applause]
mr speaker i can only hope that his
police questionnaire was a bit more
convincing than man
this year this year
this year british people face the worst
fall in living standards on record
while they're counting every penny the
prime minister is hitting them with
higher taxes
but in 2024 when there just so happens
to be a general election
they will introduce a small tax cut
that's not taking difficult decisions
it's putting the tory re-election
campaign over and above helping people
pay their bills
how did how did he find a chancellor as
utterly cynical as he is
play ballista what we have mr speaker is
a chancellor who took the tough
decisions to look after
the uk economy
throughout the pandemic who protected
who protected people up and down the
land with 408 billion pounds worth of
support
and by the way if we listen to them if
we listen to captain this is the truth
if we listen to captain hindsight
we would not have come out of we would
not have come out of lockdown in july
last year mr speaker
we would have stayed in lockdown over
christmas and new year mr speaker with
the result that the uk economy would not
be growing in the way that it is and so
we would not be able to make the
investments that we now are and under
labor we would have to tax more and
borrow more and they cannot be trusted
mr speaker with the economy
[Applause]
here
the tough decisions give me a break
we
we
know
we know
mr speaker we know who those two always
ask to pay
income stealth tax attacks on working
people
tuition fee raid a tax on working people
national insurance hike a tax on working
people
all while oil and gas companies see
unexpected bumper profits
a windfall tax would raise billions and
ease the burden on working people
mr speaker
the former ceo of bp lord john brown
says a windfall tax is justifiable
the current ceo says they have in his
words more cash than they know what to
do with
why is the prime minister more
interested in shielding oil and gas
profits than supporting working people
[Applause]
this is a classic example of what
laborers got wrong uh in their their
their period in office
the the oil and gas companies are now
investing 20 billion pounds uh mr
speaker in ensuring that we have
long-term energy supplies and i remember
the 1997 labor manifesto actually said
that there was no economic case for more
nuclear power
we are now having to we are now having
to make good the historic mistakes of
the labour party by investing in our
long-term energy supply that is what
we're doing everything that they are
proposing would mean deterring
investment meaning higher prices for
consumers and households up and down the
land being worse off
[Applause]
there we have it they're the party of
excess oil and gas profits we're the
party of working people
mr speaker
talking
talking of parties
talking of parties prime minister
he told the house
no rules were broken in downing street
during lockdown
the police have now concluded there was
widespread criminality
the ministerial code says that ministers
who knowingly mislead the house should
resign
why is he still here
hang on hang on
[Applause]
he just changed his position
i mean
we do it we do at least expect some
consistency from uh this this human
weather vein
it was it was only a week or so ago
where he was saying that i shouldn't
resign
he's got to make what is it what is his
position mr speaker uh we of course the
of course the the the the memo the
investigators must i must get on with
their job but in the meantime
uh uh let and we and they should in the
meantime in the meantime mr speaker we
are going to get on with our job and uh
what we are what we are focusing on is
tackling the cost of living uh helping
people helping people
through the spike in fuel prices the 9.1
billion that the chancellor has set out
but also mr speaking during the long
i've mentioned nuclear power i mentioned
tackling our energy supplies which labor
totally failed to do with what we're
also doing far more important perhaps
even than that mr speaker we're tackling
illiteracy and innumeracy in our schools
and i think we're investing billions in
tutoring and mr speaker that's what
we're focusing on and i think that's
what the people of this country want us
to focus on
here's darma
look there are only two possible
explanations
either he's trashing the ministerial
code
or he's claiming he was repeatedly lied
to by his own advisers but he didn't
know what was going on in his own house
in his own office
come off it
he really does think that it's one rule
for him and another rule for everyone
else
that he can pass off criminality in his
office and ask others to follow the law
that he can keep raising taxes and call
himself a tax cutter
that he can hike tax during a cost of
living crisis and get credit for giving
a bit back just before an election
when is he going to stop taking the
british public for falls
[Music]
mr speaker this is the this is the
leader of the opposition who would have
kept this country in lockdown uh made it
absolutely impossible that you know he
has zero consistency on any issue uh mr
speaker but one thing we know about is
he would like to take us back into the
eu and take us back into lockdown if he
possibly could
thanks thanks to what this government
has done uh we have unemployment back
down to the levels it was before the
pandemic the economy bigger than it was
and we have record vacancies mr speaker
the difference between them and us is is
they want to keep people mr speaker they
want to keep people on benefits we want
to help people into work and that's what
we're doing
in record numbers
they want to raise taxes we want to cut
taxes and that's what we're doing and mr
speaker and we're tackling we're
tackling illiteracy they didn't give a
damn
mr speaker and we're getting on with
making this country making this country
the best place to invest last time i
updated the highest mr speaker on the
number of unicorns that we had of
unicorns in this country that's tech
countries worth more than a billion
dollars mr speaker i said we had a
hundred i can inform you now mr speaker
that we now have 120 they don't want to
hear it but let me tell you
that's more than france that's more than
germany that's more than israel it's
more than france germany israel combined
mr speaker that's what's happening under
this government that's what's happening
because of the tough decisions we've
taken we take the tough decisions we
deliver they play politics mr speaker
thank you mr speaker the uk government's
work connecting rural areas like bracken
and radisha to superfast broadband is
going to come a lot harder tomorrow when
the welsh government withdraws its
matched funding for the scheme forcing
the cost for installation back onto
homes and businesses in my constituency
welsh labour's decision means that my
constituents will lose out as local
authorities in england continue to fund
the scheme does my right honourable
friend agree with me that broadband is
critical for the growth of the rural
economy and will he double his
government's efforts to connect my
constituents despite welsh labour
letting us down
yes
yes mr speaker and uh we're spending 69
million
already uh to support rollout of
superfast broadband in wales and uh i
wish that the uh welsh government had
not withdrawn its uh broadband scheme
but we will do our best mr speaker to
make up the difference as fast as
possible
we now come to the snp leader in
blackfood
thank you mr speaker it's good to see
the member for bridgend in the chamber
this afternoon i commend him for his
statement earlier today
mr speaker
last night
millions of families will have been
desperately trying to figure out how
they will possibly afford the 700 pound
energy price hike that will hit them
this friday
mr speaker at the very same time
tony mps were gathering across the
street for a champagne bash in the park
plaza
[Applause]
all know
[Applause]
we all know
that the tories partied during lockdown
and now they're [ __ ]
mr fabricant easter is upon us i don't
need you to ruin your easter
so let's hear
all of you
smp leader in blackfood
you can shout and scream when we're
raising the tory cost of living crisis
mr speaker
because we all know that the tories
partied during lockdown and now they're
partying through the cost of living
emergency
last week
the chancellor got it badly badly wrong
with the spring statement and ever since
the prime minister has been busy
briefing against him saying that more
needs to be done for once i agree with
the prime minister
so if the prime minister really believes
that more needs to be done can he tell
us exactly what he will order his
chancellor to do to help the millions of
families who are facing a 700 pound
price hike this friday yeah prime
minister uh mr speaker i i thank him uh
very much and uh uh he is uh he's i
think he's an error in what he says
about events last night but he is like
me a living testament to the benefits of
moderation uh in all things uh
mr speaker uh and uh i can i can assure
him i can assure him that we are we are
getting that this week for instance uh
to get to his point uh what's happening
actually is that the living wage is
going up again
uh by record amounts and thanks to what
the chancellor has done uh we are
putting 9.1 billion pounds into helping
people up and down the country and what
i might respectfully suggest is actually
i think the the scottish nationalist
government with whom as i say we work
increasingly well i think the thing they
could focus on of long-term prosperity
of scotland is the educational system
where i'm sad to see where i i'm sad to
see i'm sad to see scotland's once
glorious record of falling behind
here
what a load of absolute baloney
mr speaker the prime minister is
dangerously out of touch
food banks are warning that people are
having to choose their food
based on whether they can afford the gas
to boil it
families are having to choose what rooms
to heat or whether they can turn on the
heating at all
some
that better weather means that they can
happily sit on their hands and do
nothing until next winter they obviously
don't get or don't care that in many
parts of scotland the weather will
barely reach above freezing over the
next week yep the chancellor thinks he's
200 pound loan which is forcing people
into energy debt
is somehow a solution but it clearly
isn't so before the prime minister and
his chancellor go off on their easter
holidays while they at very least turn
this lawn into a grant and finally put
some cash into people's pockets when
they need it right now
[Music]
i thank you but of course
we are doing everything that we can the
the 9.1 billion the cold the cold
weather payments and he's right he's
right to draw attention uh to the
problem uh mr speaker we are we are
making making a huge investment in
supporting uh people right now and
another billion by the way through the
household support fund uh to help
vulnerable uh help vulnerable families
but mr speaker when he talks about the
cost of energy in in scotland how
absolutely preposterous uh that the
scottish nationalist party uh should
still be opposed uh to the use of any of
our uh native hydrocarbons in this
country uh with with the result with the
result that we actually have to we that
the europeans are importing uh oil and
gas from putin's russia uh mr speaker
totally absurd
it's true
just for the record it's national party
let's go to mark fletcher thank you mr
speaker
following on from the publication of the
school's white paper one of my most
important campaigns is to secure
provision of quality post-16 education
within the polls over constituency where
there is currently none young people in
my constituency have to travel long
distances at considerable cost to access
their education will my right honourable
friend meet with me to discuss how we
can right this wrong for the young
people at the world's over constituency
and give them the education that they
deserve yeah yeah prime minister yes
i thank him very much and uh he's a
great uh champion for bolsonville for
his uh constituents a free subs and
subsidized travelers provided to bolster
students uh traveling so far to two uh
of these uh of the three excellent
colleges that uh are going to be
offering t levels uh from 2023 uh but i
will make sure that uh uh he gets a
meeting uh with uh my right-hand from
the education secretary uh to discuss
further what we can do
and david during the second world war my
grandmother like countless other people
across our country
opened her home to evacuees
including two german jewish boys
over 70 years later the british people
want to shelter desperate refugees again
two weeks ago i was speaking to refugee
families on the ukrainian polish border
at medica
some desperately wanted to come to our
country
one elderly couple told me however
they've been told that it's just too
complicated
now the government's own figures say the
same
paperwork is being put ahead of people
mr speaker
when wealthy businessmen
from over 50 countries can come to the
uk visa-free
why does the prime minister insist
that a traumatized ukrainian mother and
child
must first fill out a visa form
minister
mrs big i think we had we i'm thank you
very much and um he and he's right about
the generosity of his country and uh and
and his right to draw attention to his
own family's uh generosity in this
matter everybody i think is is pulling
together the number of people who
come forward to offer their homes is is
incredible
um but i really don't think that he
should uh he should deprecate what the
uh the uk is offering we've already
given 25 000 25 000 people have already
got visas uh mr speaker we are
processing 1 000 a day 1 000 a day and
there is no limit there is no upper
limit to the number that we could take
and this is a country that has already
been the most generous in taking people
from afghanistan the 15 000 under
operation pitting 104 000 applications
from uh from the hong kong chinese uh
this is a country that is overwhelmingly
generous to people coming in fear of
their lives from yes it is mr speaker
and so and so is this government
john ambassador thank you very much uh
mr speaker i don't think anybody
involved in partnering operations over
the last 10 or 20 years can fail to be
humbled by the extraordinary courage and
commitment of the ukrainian people in
defending their country aided and
abetted by the lethal aid from this
country of which they're all
appreciative of this government and this
prime minister being first out the door
to deliver that but would
would the prime minister agree with me
that whilst others may now begin to tire
now is actually the time to double down
on the aid that we give to ukraine that
actually we might end up breaking a
pretty poor russian army and bring peace
to that part of the world whilst
consigning the likes of vladimir putin
to the dustbin of history where he
belongs
uh mr speaker i think that is absolutely
right thank you very much i thank him
for his own uh bravery in in going to
see for himself uh only the only the
other day but uh mr speaker yes it is
right that we should double down on on
uh military defensive support in the in
the way that we are uh but and by the
way can anybody imagine a labour
government eight of whom uh adam whose
front bench voted to get rid of our
nuclear deterrent
can you imagine yes they did can you
imagine recently can you imagine them uh
doing the same uh we will go on we will
go on with that mr speaker uh but what
we will also do
and i i hope we have the support of the
opposition in this is make sure that
there is no backsliding on sanctions uh
by any of our friends and partners
around the world in fact we need now to
ratchet up the economic pressure on
vladimir putin and it is certainly
inconceivable that any sanctions could
be taken off
simply because there is a ceasefire
mr speaker that would be absolutely
unthinkable in my view
thank you mr speaker households are
experiencing soaring energy costs we're
in the middle of a global climate
emergency
against this backdrop norway can feed
energy into our national grid at a cost
of one pound 36 per megawatt hour
france paid 17
per megawatt hour
germany the netherlands and luxembourg
pay nothing to feed into our group
can the prime minister then explain why
scotland's renewable sector has been
punished with grid connection charges of
seven pounds 36 per megawatt hour
prime minister
mr speaker scotland's renewable sector
is leading the world
and uh i i'm i'm grateful to uh all the
scottish government for the scottish
government for all the the help and
support that they are giving in
developing that incredible resource in
the north sea i think that there is also
a role by the way for hydrocarbons as we
transition uh mr speaker but what we
need to do is make sure that we have a
grid we have a grid uh that enables us
to take that electricity onshore and
transmitted around the country and that
is what i will be setting out in the uh
british energy security strategy mr
speaker that is the investment the
long-term investment that this country
needs and which and which uh the party's
opposite completely failed to address
greg smith thank you mr speaker last
week following a huge resident and
parish council-led campaign the planning
application for a new mega prison in my
constituency was refused but would my
right honourable friend agree that with
the proposals for that site being very
close to where hs2 and east west rail
cross this is a matter of fairness
whereby communities already suffering at
the hands of the construction of big
state infrastructure should not be asked
to take more and will he instruct the
ministry of justice not to appeal this
planning decision
[Music]
uh well i i i thank my honorable friend
who is a a doubty campaigner for his
his constituency he's made an important
point about a planning matter about
which i don't think i should really uh
comment but i'm sure that uh the
relevant ministers would have heard him
uh loud and clear eric london
thank you mr speaker with the government
losing an estimated 4 billion crown
pound to fraud in the furlough scheme
surely the prime minister should have
tackled that fraud especially when in
his own party in north tyneside
furlough was claimed for a member of
party staff even though he continued to
work
if she's really saying uh mr speaker
that we should not have rolled out the
furlough scheme uh at the speed that we
did
then i think everybody in this country
understands that it was a
a heroic thing and i remember two years
ago mr speaker two they were yammering
and clamoring for us to go faster
and we did mr speaker we produced a
fantastic team and yes fraudsters uh
will be hunted down we put another 100
million into tracking down fraud in this
country 23 billion pounds a year were
lost under labour in fraud
a year james sunderland
mr speaker thank you i was delighted to
learn this week that 37 of the 39 state
schools in brattle constituency are now
graded good or outstanding
will the prime minister join with me in
thanking our fantastic teachers staff
governors and pupils and does he agree
that the new education white paper
offers a blueprint for our schools that
we can all be proud of
yes i do mr speaker it's a fantastic
white paper
over two million tons of edible food is
wasted on farms and factories every year
and funding was introduced in 2019 to
cover the costs of getting food to
charities to reach those in need however
the prime minister will know his
government have now cut that critical
funding to zero
mr speaker funding for food waste
diversion helps support community
projects like for example three hills
community supermarket in glasgow so can
a prime minister explain why is ignoring
calls from feeding britain good food
scotland and fair share to continue this
worthwhile initiative and instead
cutting off a lifeline to those
struggling with the cost of living
crisis
uh i thank you very much i i think he's
referring to
uh the strategy that we have for for
food waste as far as i as far as i know
we continue to support it but i will be
uh happy to update him uh by that
lucia
very much mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for his earlier remarks
concerning the donna ockendon report
into avoidable maternity deaths and
injuries at the shrewsbury and helford
hospital trust the report makes for
devastating reading the more so because
women's voices were ignored
my constituent haley matthews begged
staff for a c-section throughout her
36-hour labour but was forced into a
natural birth her son jack arrived blue
and floppy and within hours of his birth
he tragically died
will the prime minister join me in
offering heartfelt sympathies to all the
families affected and also grateful
thanks to the
1862 women
who shared their experiences with the
ochenton review to ensure that maternity
care is safer
kinder and more compassionate for the
women that come after them
hello minister uh i i thank my
honourable friend for her question i
think everybody uh will thank the the
women concerned for uh taking up the
issue in the way that uh uh that they
have and will extend
our heartfelt uh sympathies to uh the
the victims and their families and for
what they've suffered it is very
important that uh people get the answers
that they deserve mr speaker but also uh
that we have the the right approach uh
to uh to this issue in in the future and
that's why we're investing very
substantially in maternity services and
also of course uh very substantially in
uh in midwives and in our nhs all
together
thank you prime minister every day i
hear from more and more of my brother
and constituents who are struggling to
put food on the table to
keep their lights on to fuel their cars
the office of budget responsibility
estimates the government's measures will
only offset falling living standards by
a third this is the biggest financial
squeeze since the 1950s prime minister
don't blame ukraine don't blame kovid
this is down to your government's
policies and your political choices
i do agree that people are facing a very
tough time at the moment and uh we've
got to do everything that we i don't
agree with her analysis but i think that
the causes are certainly to do with the
the uh inflationary impact of the world
coming out of of kobe and the energy
price spike is is is at the root of it
and and what we are doing uh mr speaker
is to help people with a universal
credit which we've lifted by a thousand
pounds help people with uh the living
wage uh which is going up now by a
record amount mr speaker and and cutting
taxes on on working people in the way
that in the way that we are
but of course we can't uh do everything
uh mr speaker right now and uh what we
will do uh is ensure that we have a
stronger economic performance and we
have people in work and the most
important thing is that we have uh
people getting into work now in a way
that wasn't possible certainly wouldn't
have been possible if we'd stuck to the
uh the policies that were proposed uh by
by the labour opposition uh and that's
why we have a strong economy uh and
that's and that is the best recipe
better to be off benefits and into work
and that's what we're doing here clark
thank you mr speaker one of my earliest
campaigns was to reopen stafford's shire
hall so i'm delighted that this iconic
building is finally set to reopen this
summer so can i thank the government for
providing 1.6 million in funding to
create a hub for small businesses in the
shire hall but can i also ask my
honorable friend to help regenerate the
rest of stafford town centre and our
high streets to help level up the west
midlands and support our local
businesses
prime minister i thank my little friend
for her fantastic work to reopen uh shah
hall she's a a passionate campaigner uh
for stafford for stafford and stafford
was awarded over 14 uh million pounds uh
lately mr speaker through the future
high streets fund fun
thank you mr speaker my constituency has
one of the highest rates of child
poverty in the entire country with too
many already struggling between heating
and eating the government's recent real
terms social security cut will now push
even more families children and
pensioners into desperation does the
prime minister agree that the biggest
squeeze in household finances since
records began does not come out of the
blue but is due to conservative
economics and the notion that once
someone has the pleasure of partying the
rest of us should suffer
i'm minister all right
no mr speaker we're absolutely uh
dedicated uh to leveling up across our
our entire country and making sure uh
that we reduce poverty and and that's
why i'm proud that there are now half a
million uh fewer kids actually in
worthless households uh 200 000 fewer
kids
200 000 fewer in poverty uh mr speaker
and 1.3 million fewer in absolute
poverty and the way we've done that that
way we've done that the way we've done
that mr speaker is by helping people
into work and we're going to go further
investing in more work coaches uh
massively increasing our training budget
so that people get the skills that they
need that's our approach uh mr speaker
helping people by getting them into work
[Music]
today's announcement by our serving
united kingdom judges of their
withdrawal from the hong kong court to
final appeal is now the right decision
and i support it as does my right
honourable friend does he agree with me
that on this sad day for the people of
hong kong and at a time when the
international rule of law is under
unprecedented challenge it is for us
here in britain to stand up for what is
right to be resolute in the face of
tyranny and to make sure that the
international rules-based order is
defended at every opportunity
prime minister
i i thank my right honourable friend
very much and i i know how passionately
he's campaigned on this issue uh himself
and i i can tell him uh that i and i
want to thank the judges in in hong
kong's court for everything that they've
uh been doing but i think that they've
evidently concluded that the uh the
constraints of the national security law
make it impossible for them to continue
uh to serve in the way that uh they
would want i appreciate and i understand
uh their uh their decision it is vital
that we all continue uh to make our
points to the chinese as i did uh in my
conversation with president xi uh the
other day about uh freedom in hong kong
and about the treatment uh the treatment
of the uyghurs and we will continue to
do that
katherine west thank you very much mr
speaker gas and electric prices and
bills are through the roof that just
about managing are no longer managing
coming to surgeries queuing at food
banks last week the government had a
golden opportunity to tackle this
why the devil didn't they take that
opportunity to do something and relieve
the pressure on our constituents
mr speaker i i i understand the pressure
that people are under uh but the
but the uh but the best the best thing
we can do rather than endlessly taxing
more and borrowing more uh is is make
sure that we support people through this
tough time which we are but also ensure
that we have a strong and growing
economy in which we get people into work
so we're so we're cutting the cost of of
energy but we're also taking the long
term decisions which the party opposite
uh failed to do to invest in our energy
for the future
so roger gale
mr speaker today's updated government
figures
show that of 28 300 applications
submitted under the sponsorship scheme
by people displaced in putin's war
just
2700
have been processed
could my right honourable friend please
tell the house how many to date
of those people have actually arrived in
the united kingdom
will he give his support to my noble
friend lord harrington to cut through
the home office red tape
simplify the application process and get
people into the country
mr speaker we're processing a thousand a
day and uh i i think that the i think
that the country
25 000 visas have already been issued as
i just as i just told the house mr
speaker uh almost 200 000 families homes
have have opened uh their arms to
ukrainians coming in fear of their lives
and there is no limit on the scheme
i think uh we can be incredibly proud of
what the uk is doing
patricia gibson thank you mr speaker a
cornerstone of the last conservative
manifesto was a guarantee that the basic
state pension would rise by either 2.5
the inflation rate or earnings growth
whichever was highest instead from april
the state pension will rise by less than
half of the current inflation rate how
does the prime minister explain this
abject betrayal
of some of the most vulnerable people in
our communities who are squeezed by
rocketing energy and food prices on the
one hand and the mindlessness of this
government on the other yeah
[Applause]
actually mr speaker what we've done is
through the triple lock protected uh
pensioners uh so that uh their incomes
as a result of the triple lock are 720
pounds higher
uh than they would have been if we just
uh relied on inflation as it is uh their
incomes uh continue to increase uh with
inflation and they've gone up mr speaker
faster and further than those who are in
work we look after elderly people and we
always will
john barron thank you mr speaker on
monday the foreign secretary agreed that
we need to expand our soft power
capabilities in these uncertain times
and yet the government is imminently
about to make a funding decision that
could see may see the closure of british
council country operations and a
reduction in its international footprint
will the prime minister now intervene to
ensure this doesn't happen given that i
know he understands and appreciates the
important work the council does yeah
yeah
very happy to meet my honorable friend
uh on this on this issue and i kept his
campaign on it uh many times but i can
tell him that the the british council
which i have a huge regard has received
massive grant and indeed loans uh to
allow allow them to continue uh their
activities
thank you thank you mr speaker you'll
forgive me if i i may start but given
the prime minister's uh preferences for
both fantasy castles and peppa pig he's
very welcome to come and visit uh zog
playland at warwick castle this weekend
in warwick and levington as across the
country cost of living crunch is really
serious energy bills as we've heard
looking to double by the end of this
year yeah food up 10 to 15 by year end
fuel already 22 up year on year it must
be hard for the prime minister to stay
in touch with financial reality given
that donors and friends pay for flights
and holidays and many of his bills
and we also have we also have a 200
million dollar
man chancellor
a 200 million
chancellor
who's so out of touch he's
so out of touch
so out of touch he's contactless
mr
speaker the public believes
you will be sitting down
so please
i hope we've come to the end of the
question
so out of touch is contactless
mr speaker the public believes
the government
shut up and be quiet behave yourselves
i hope that's the end of the question i
think the prime minister's got the gist
of it because i certainly am the prime
minister okay okay can i say to the
honorable much as i admire his his style
i think be better as a sort of light
essay in the guardian
what we're doing mr speaker is is
tackling the tackling the cost of living
uh by dealing with the spike in energy
prices and making sure that we take the
right long-term decisions to take this
country forward which right decisions
are that party opposite completely
shocked
then sacks me
yeah yeah yeah
and i welcome what this government is
doing to help where it can with the cost
of living crisis yeah but in north devon
and across the southwest we have a
housing crisis that needs urgent action
will my right honourable friend meet
with me to better understand the
severity and complexity of our housing
shortage and potential steps the
government may take
prime minister
my uh honorable friend is
absolutely right and uh
she's right about the the need to
provide local homes uh for local people
and uh we we totally understand that i'm
very uh and that's why we're building a
record number of homes by the way mr
speaker in spite of all the difficulties
in spite of all the difficulties that
we've faced and that's why we've
introduced higher rates of stamp duty on
second homes mr speaker
remove the second homes discount and
we're using uh 11.5 billion to build 180
000 affordable homes across the country
it is always the conservatives who build
affordable homes
it's true and it's labor who talk about
it
final question sir
thank you very much mr speaker last
friday it emerged to be an oil spill in
beverly brook a river which flows
through richmond park to the thames
black waste oil and iridescence can now
be seen along 13 kilometers of the
watercourse posing a serious threat to
the fish and local wildlife the
environment agencies are investigating
that they are understaffed and
underfunded while also battling war
against water companies over sewage
discharge will the government commit to
strengthening the powers of the office
for environmental protection as the lib
dems tried to do through the environment
bill so that it is able to hold the
government and other public authorities
to account over environmental damage in
the same way the european commission was
able to yeah prime minister
uh i i i know what's behind her question
uh um mr speaker it's a desire to return
to the jurisdiction of the of the
european union
what we want to do is make sure that we
use our landmark environment bill to
continue to improve the quality of our
rivers and that's what we're doing
we'll just let the chamber clear before
we start the statement
so perhaps as expected the cost of
living uh a real focus for the labour
party uh from the prime minister and
also uh touched on partygate as well
we'll get political reaction uh to what
happened uh in the house a little while
but first a bit of breaking news we can
bring you and tracy connolly now she you
may remember is the mother of the child
known as baby p
she is now to be released from prison
there was a lot of controversy about
this she was jailed back in 2009
for a minimum of five years for causing
or allowing the death of her son peter
at their home in tottenham in north
london and he'd suffered months of
horrific abuse at the hands of her
partner and his brother a spokesman for
the parole board says that they can
confirm that a panel of the parole board
has directed the release of tracy
connolly following an oral hearing
parole board decisions are solely
focused on what risk a prisoner could
represent to the public if released and
whether that risk is manageable in the
community and parole reviews are
undertaken thoroughly and with extreme
care protecting the public on number one
priority uh let's go back to the commons
sajid javed health secretary he's going
to speak about the statement about
maternity failures was set up in 2017 in
response to concerns from berea
maternity at shrewsbury and telford
hospital nhs trust
its original scope was to cover the
cases of 23 families
but since it began
sadly
many more families have reported
concerns
due to this tragically high number of
cases
and the importance of this work to
patient safety early conclusions were
published in an initial report in
december twenty twenty
we accepted all of the recommendations
from this first report and the nhs is
now taking them forward
today the second and final report has
been published
this is one of the largest inquiries
relating to a single service in the
history of the nhs
looking at experiences of almost 1
500 families from 2000 to 2019
i'd like to update the house on the
findings of this report and then turn to
the actions that we are taking as a
result
this report paints a tragic and
harrowing picture of repeated failures
in care over two decades
which led to unimaginable trauma for so
many people
rather than moments of joy and happiness
for these families their experience of
maternity care was one of tragedy and
distress
and the effects of these failures
were felt across families communities
and generations
the cases in this report
are stark
and deeply upsetting
of twelve cases where a mother had died
the report concludes that in three
quarters of those cases
the care could have been significantly
improved
it also examined 44 cases of hie a brain
injury caused by cancer by oxygen
deprivation
two-thirds of these cases featured
significant and major concerns in the
care provided to the mother
and
the report says from almost 500 cases of
stillbirth
one in four were found to have major
concerns in maternity care which if
managed appropriately
might or would have resulted in a
different outcome
when i met with donna ockerdon last week
she told me about basic oversights
at every level of patient care
including one case
where important clinical information
was kept on post-it notes
which were then swept into the bin by
cleaners
with tragic consequences for a newborn
baby
and her family
in addition
there were repeated cases where the
trust failed to undertake serious
incident investigations
and
where investigations did take place
they didn't follow the standards that
would have been expected
these persistent failings continued as
late as 2019
and multiple opportunities to address
them were ignored
including by the trust board who were
accountable for these services
reviews from external bodies failed to
identify the substandard care that was
taking place and some of the findings
gave false reassurances about maternity
services at the trust
the cqc only rated maternity services
inadequate for safety in 2018
which is unacceptable given the huge
deficiencies in care that are outlined
in this report
the report also highlights serious
issues with the culture within the trust
for instance two-thirds of staff were
surveyed and reported that they had
witnessed cases of bullying and some
staff members withdrew their cooperation
with the report within weeks of
publication
the first report already concluded i
quote
that there was a culture within the
trust to keep cesarean rates below
because they were perceived as the
essence of good maternity care end quote
and today's report adds that and i quote
again
many women thought any deviation from
normality meant a cesarean section was
needed and this was then denied to them
by the trust
mr speaker it is right that both the
royal college of obstetricians and
gynecologists and the royal college of
midwives have said recently that they
regret their campaign for so-called
normal births
it is vital that across maternity
services that we focus on safe and
personalized care
where the voice of the mother is heard
throughout
the report shows a systemic failure to
listen to families affected
many of whom who had been doggedly
persistent in raising issues over
several years
one mother said
that she felt like a lone voice in the
wind
bereaved families told the report that
they were treated in a way that lacked
sensitivity and empathy and appallingly
in some cases
the trust blamed these mothers for the
trauma that they had been through
in the words of donna ockerdon
the trust
failed to investigate failed to learn
and failed to improve
we entrust the nhs with our care
often when we are at our most vulnerable
in return we expect the highest
standards i've seen with my own family
the brilliant care the nhs maternity
services can offer
but when those standards are not met
we must act firmly
and the failures of care and compassion
that are set out in this report have
absolutely no place in the nhs
to all the families that have suffered
so greatly
i am sorry
the report clearly shows that you were
failed by a service that was there to
help you and your loved ones
to bring life into this world
we will make the changes that the report
says are needed at both a local and
national level
mr speaker i know that honourable
members
and those families who have suffered
would want reassurances that the
individuals who are responsible for
these serious and repeated failures will
be held to account
i'm sure that the house will understand
that it is not appropriate for me to
name individuals at this stage
however i'd like to reassure honourable
members that a number of people who were
working at the trust at the time of the
incident have been suspended or struck
off from the professional register and
members of senior management have also
been removed from their posts
there is also an active police
investigation
operation lincoln
which is looking at around 600 cases
given that this is a live investigation
i'm sure that honorable members will
recognize that i'm not able to comment
further on that
today's report recognizes that since the
initial report was published in 2020 we
have taken important steps to improve
maternity care this includes 95 million
pounds of maternity services across
england to boost the maternity workforce
to fund programs for training
development and leadership
the second report makes a series of
further recommendations
it contains 66 for the local trust
15 for the wider nhs and three for me as
secretary of state
the local trust
nhs england and the department of health
and social care will be accepting all 84
recommendations
earlier today i spoke to the chief
executive of the trust who was not in
the post during the time a period that
was examined by this report
i made it clear how seriously i take
this report and the failures that were
uncovered and i reinforced that the
recommendations must be acted on
promptly
but as the report identifies
there are wider lessons that must also
be learned
and it contains a series of actions that
should be considered by all trusts that
provide maternity services
i've asked nhs england to write to all
of these trusts instructing them to
assess themselves against these actions
and nhs england will be setting out a
renewed delivery plan that reflects
these recommendations
i'm also taking forward the specific
recommendations that donna ocadon has
asked me to put in place
the first is the need to further expand
the maternity workforce just a few days
ago the nhs announced a 127 million
pound funding boost for maternity
services across england this will
bolster the maternity workforce even
further and it will also fund programs
to strengthen leadership retention and
capital for neonatal maternity care
second we will take forward the
recommendation to create a working group
independent of the maternity
transformation program with joint
leadership from the royal college of
midwives and the royal college of
obstetricians and gynecologists
finally donna ocaden said that she
endorses the proposals that i announced
in january to create a special health
authority to continue the maternity
investigation program that is currently
run by the healthcare safety
investigation branch
and again we will take her proposals
forward and the ss sha will start its
work from april next year
i would like to thank donna okadan and
her whole team
for the forensic and compassionate
approach that she has taken
throughout this distressing inquiry
this report has given a voice at last to
those families who were ignored and so
grievously wronged
and it provides a valuable blueprint for
safety and safe maternity care in this
country for years to come
finally mr speaker i would like to pay
tribute to the families
whose tireless advocacy was instrumental
to this review being set up in the first
place
i cannot imagine
how difficult it must have been for them
to come forward and to tell their
stories
and this report is a testament to the
courage and the fortitude
that they have shown in the most
harrowing of circumstances
mr speaker
this report is a devastating account
of bedrooms that are empty
families that are bereft
and loved ones taken before their time
we will act swiftly
so that no families have to go through
the same pain in the future
i commend this statement to the house
just before we start what i would say is
the choir around the secretary some very
important stench has gone over so i
would offer the flu event six minutes we
come to shadow minister for russia
thank you mr speaker i thank the
secretary of state for advance of his
statement
i'm pleased to be able to respond to
this statement today not just as the
shadow minister for patient safety but
as a woman and as a new mother
i would like to thank donna okindon and
her team for this report
i would like to thank the families that
have come forward we would not be here
today without the persistence and the
resilience they have shown for over 20
years in their fight for justice
today marks an important milestone for
hundreds of families who have been
seeking justice
the opening reports lays bare the
harrowing truth of what those families
had to face
and why their fight for justice has been
such a fierce one cries for help going
unheard
parents having to
try and resuscitate their own children
because there was no one there to help
women and babies dying needlessly
because they simply were not listened to
that women were silenced and ignored at
their most vulnerable when they were
relying on the nhs to keep them safe is
shameful
no woman no woman should ever have to
face going into hospital to give birth
and not know whether she and her baby
will come out alive
these were not just one-off or isolated
incidents of negligence
this was the institutional failure of a
system which failed to take up the many
opportunities to realize that he had a
serious problem
we are where we are today because of the
persistence and the resilience of those
families and their refusal to give up
the fight to expose those failings
and the only comfort we can offer them
is that their voices have been heard
and that we commit today across this
house to ensure these failings are never
repeated
for far too long patient safety issues
and the voices of women have been an
afterthought in health
leading to the kind of crisis we saw in
shrewsbury
this needs to change
patient safety must be a priority for
both health professionals and ministers
so
today i welcome that the secretary of
state has committed to the local actions
for learning for shrewsbury and telford
hospital trust
in full and all the immediate and
essential actions on the wider system
so will the secretary of state come to
this house later on this year to update
on the progress being made on these
actions
the report makes clear that you cannot
run a safe service without a culture of
transparency and
accountability so will the secretary of
state set out how he intends to ensure
an open culture within the health
service with the willingness to learn
within maternity services and for future
failings to be identified far more
quickly
underpinning issues of maternity care as
is the case across so much of our nhs is
workforce
only 10 months ago as a first-time
mother i experienced just how
stretched to the limits maternity
services are
the nhs now is losing more midwives it's
losing midwives faster than it can
actually recruit them
a recent cqc survey shows that almost a
quarter of women were unable to get help
when they needed during labour
hundreds of pregnant women were turned
away from maternity wars last year
because they were not they were not the
staff available to care for them
so can the secretary of state tell the
house what he's doing to ensure that nhs
recruits the midwives it needs
and what he is doing to keep the
midwives we have in post
it's only with the necessary workforce
that the nhs will be able to ensure
women receive the care that meets their
needs and priority prioritizes their
safety
the security and respect
that security and respect is all that
the families who suffered so much at
shoes we
and all that the women who put their and
their babies lives in the hands of nhs
want thank you mr speaker
we now come to the sorry secretary no
come to secretary of state
thank you mr speaker
and can i thank the honorable lady uh
for uh her remarks and it's not often we
get to say this in this chamber but i
agree with her wholeheartedly and what
she just
shared with the house she's right to
talk about this as a as a fight for
justice then she's right to point to had
these brave families not come forward
and been so persistent in in in coming
forward with what had been done to them
what had gone wrong this inquiry may
never have happened and she's absolutely
right to
to say that but also to talk about
institutional failure at this trust and
the first report set that out in some
detail and today we're seeing that in in
in much more uh detail she talked
rightly about uh patient safety and she
will know that the government is has
already set out plans to appoint a
patient safety commissioner and that
that particular appointment will be made
soon but we need to do much much more on
that and that is why with the interim
report
it was absolutely right to accept all
the recommendations including the
immediate and urgent actions that were
needed i think in that report the
interim report there were seven of those
and 27 local actions and i can also tell
her the house that the trust has
implemented all of those actions from
the interim report
that was then backed by the 95 million
pounds of extra funding at the time and
then also as i as i said a moment ago
the recommendations in this final report
many more recommendations quite rightly
so uh that they have all been accepted
and backed by at least 127 million
pounds of funding much of that will go
to workforce when it comes to workforce
also i think it's also worth uh saying
because she's right about the need to to
increase the size of the workforce
especially uh in terms of midwives that
when it comes to acceptances
for student nurses and midwives it's at
the last year's acceptance i think were
the highest thing that the country had
seen in decades but clearly there's much
more to do
come to the church committee jeremy
helmand thank you mr speaker today's
report goes beyond my darkest fears when
i commissioned it as health secretary in
2016 i was approached by 23 families and
we hear today that over 200 babies might
be alive today
if uh better care had been provided i
want to thank donna ockendon and her
team for an incredibly thorough
investigation
and i also want to thank the health
secretary for his compassionate and
comprehensive response to the house
today um donna ochen doesn't use the
word recommendation she talks about
immediately essential actions
so so can i ask him what is his deadline
by when all those actions will be
implemented because that is something
that every expectant mother in the
country desperately wants to know can i
gently say to him that whilst i warmly
welcome more midwives and more doctors
it is not consistent to do that and to
vote down the amendment from the house
of lords today on the health bill which
would make sure that we never had those
shortages again and can i too finally
pay tribute
to richard and rihanna stanton davis
kaylee and colin griffiths richard and
rhiannon came to talk to me about their
daughter kate who died in 2009.
colin and kaylee's daughter pippa died
in 2016 when i was health secretary
and um there
because of the blame culture and the
culture of fear in the nhs it was left
to them
and many other families
to fight for justice can this be the
last time that we put that burden on the
shoulders of bereaved families and build
a culture in the nhs which is open
transparent
accepts things go wrong but hungry to
learn from mistakes so that we never
again repeat tragedies
yes
service day mr speaker i agree very much
with my right honourable friend and i
also want to acknowledge that ultimately
this report took place because of his
decision uh to ask donna ocon to do this
independent review but he's right that
he in turn did that uh because of the of
the bravery of families that had come to
see him especially rhiannon davies and
richard stanton and kaylee and colin
griffiths and of course there are many
other uh families he's he's absolutely
right to say that he is
it is questioned about the immediate and
essential uh actions with the interim
report there were seven such actions the
truster has implemented all of those
across the nhs uh they either are fully
or partially implemented uh the uh the
uh with this report uh there are also uh
such actions uh recommended and they are
the implementation of that has already
begun of course we've just received the
report uh but i have asked for a
timetable by when that will all will be
done and i want to see that done as
quickly as possible and then also uh is
his point about workforce is very
important and i hope that he welcomes
for the first time the nhs has been
asked to set out a a 15-year workforce
plan
hello morgan thank you mr speaker um i
just want to join my honourable
colleagues across the house and start by
thanking all of the families who've
bravely come forward to share their
experiences
in particular kaylee collin rhiannon and
richard whose persistence have led to
this review
and i hope that women and babies across
shropshire and telford and weekend and
the uk will be safer in the future as a
result of their bravery
i'd also like to thank donna rockington
and her team for their thoroughness in
reviewing so many tragic cases
i'm sure the secretary of state will
agree with me that this can never be
allowed to happen again and that the
deaths of these 201 babies must not be
in vain this must be a turning point for
maternity services in england
donna condon has endorsed the findings
of the health and social care selection
select committee and recommended that an
immediate investment of 200 to 350
million pounds in annum is required to
keep women safe so i welcome the
secretary of state guarantees that the
immediate and essential actions will be
implemented but i'd like to ask him
whether he'll be able to commit the
additional resources recommended by
docker and donna okindon today thank you
so much can i thank the honorable lady
for her comments and assure her that
that her constituents those throughout
shropshire telford and the re-king will
be safer as a result of those brave
families coming forward and
and this report and indeed families
across the across england and when it
comes to resources uh the honourable
lady would have heard me talk about the
95 million that was given at the time of
the interim report plus another 127
million uh given in the last few days
for maternity services and we will keep
that under review
lucy allen thank you mr speaker and i
too would like to thank the secretary of
state for his very welcome statement
today i'd also like to thank minister
caulfield for her work in this area
which has been excellent i want to pay
tribute to my right honourable friend
the member for southwest surrey for
everything he has done for patient
safety uh he has led the way and i'm so
grateful to him for this um does my
right older friend believe that what we
have seen at shrewsbury telford hospital
trust is indicative of a culture where
senior management were unaccountable
where no one felt responsible where
failings were minimized where poor care
is normalized and where women's voices
were not heard and will he do everything
he can to increase
accountability of senior management
across the nhs so the institutional
blindness as we have seen here can never
again cause such harm to those who put
their trust in the nhs
seriously
can i first just thank my honorable
friend for
uh her approach and her role in helping
to make this report happen and how she's
worked with with me and ministers in my
department on this most important of
issues she's right to talk about the
importance of culture especially where
it is absolutely clear from this report
that the voices of women were not heard
time and time again they were not heard
and and i want to reassure her that we
will implement all the recommendations
in this report but even broader than
that when it comes to women's voices
that will be at the heart of the
upcoming women's health strategy
publicly
thank you mr speaker today is an
important day for maternity safety and
we rightly pay tribute to the families
directly affected so many of whom have
given evidence to the oppendent review
i want to quote james tickle who lost
his baby son joshua during the more
convey maternity scandal
he said one of the most harmful
experiences for the more convey families
was seeing influential people in the
maternity world diminish the findings of
the investigation report
i joined james titum in saying we must
not allow that to happen with this
report and i urge the secretary of state
to ensure instead that the bereaved
families should be allowed a process of
truth reconciliation and healing instead
of any denial of the truth of what
happened
seriously
i i agree with the honourable lady and
she's right to raise the importance of
the morgan bay investigation where i
believe the report was completed in 2015
and there were 44 recommendations from
that uh i know that uh some of those
recommendations that 18 that were
specifically for the trust uh have have
all been implemented and there were 26
for the wider nhs that are being
implemented
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my original friend for both the tone and
the substance of his response to this uh
devastating report today and also to add
my voice to the consensus across the
house uh that the the way this is being
handled uh is uh is utterly vital and we
must make sure that the nhs does take on
board uh uh don orkanden's
recommendations uh she and her team of
over 90 experienced clinicians need are
properly being thanked for the work
they've done they painstakingly reviewed
these cases going back some 20 years and
it must have been harrowing for them as
of course it has been for all the
families so tragically effective had to
relive their tragedy
in particular i'd like to praise the
courage and tenacity of rhiannon stanton
davis and richard davies who were my
constituents when they lost their baby
kate in truly awful and tragically
avoidable circumstances
it was they who kept pressing for
answers from shrewsbury and telford
hospital trust and which led me to take
them to see my right honourable friend
the member for surrey southwest when he
was health secretary who agreed to
launch this review five years ago
they are no longer my constituents and i
understand they're now keen
understandably to focus their attention
on their family having been living with
this trauma since 2009.
i'll ask some questions for the
secretary if i may
does my right honourable friend uh
recognize that the ocardon review has
raised fundamental questions for
maternity services across the nhs over
the culture of so-called normal birth
and how a focus on targets under
successive governments
rather than patient outcomes can distort
clinical best practice and tragically
patient safety
and from his discussion with the current
chief executive that he touched on in
his remarks is he satisfied that the
current management and clinical teams at
south have accepted the local actions
for learning made by the initial
ochenton report and are committed to
study and implement rapidly all further
recommendations specific to this trust
and finally what reassurance can he give
to the thousand
thousands of expectant mothers in
shropshire and telford enrique that the
maternity services there are safe and
that patient safety is paramount
first can i thank my uh honourable
friend for the way he has also worked
with my uh department and and my
predecessor representing his
constituency the way he has throughout
this
uh he's he's talked about the so-called
normal birth and he's right to use the
the
you to say so called because
really
the only normal birth is a safe birth
and that is that is what the nhs should
be working to and that clearly did not
happen in this trust and
and this report has made that absolutely
clear but just as importantly as set out
a number of recommendations including uh
for my honorable friend's local nhs
trust and and i can absolutely reassure
him including from my conversation
earlier today with the current chief
executive that uh the
recommendations from the interim report
have all been implemented by his local
trust and the ones that uh in this
report have all been accepted
you mr speaker mr speaker can i start by
paying tribute to all the families
affected
and also to thank donna ogdenton and her
team for her recommendations speaker
more midwives are leaving the profession
than joining it and so we cannot run
equally safe services across all nhs
trusts without the appropriate staffing
levels
and so
i hope the secretary of state will be
able to outline in further details what
the government is doing to ensure that
we have safe staffing levels across all
nhs trusts for
in order to provide care for pregnant
women
service day the honourable lady mr
speaker's right to talk about the
importance of having the right workforce
certainly more more midwives i can tell
her that that last year there were 30
185 acceptances for nursing and
midwifery courses the highest in in a
decade and also in terms of recruitment
supported by some of this extra funding
i've talked about today
there the government has put in place
your grants for for students to to to
take on courses and also where
appropriate focus on international
recruitment too
laura trot thank you mr speaker this
courageous report today is clear that
keeping cesarean section rates
artificially low contributed to babies
dying
i'm pleased that following a
recommendation from the cross party
health and social care committee nhs
trusts are no longer being assessed on
performance for their cesarean rates
will the secretary of state go further
will he ensure that we look at where
cesarean section rates remain
artificially low in trusts so this
dangerous
normal birth ideology is eradicated from
the nhs once and for all
so
mr speaker the the answer is yes
thank you mr speaker
and again i i would also like to pay a
tribute to the families in what is truly
a shocking report but could i ask the
secretary of state in in addition to the
issues identified around the culture
within this particular trust
um i'm sorry i haven't gone into all the
recommendations are the recommendations
in terms of governance for boards
boards have a key role in holding their
executives to account
and will he
on that point
be writing to boards to
make them aware of their
responsibilities about that and could i
also ask the
secretary of state what the implications
are for the
national clinical audit of the
confidential inquiries into maternal and
infant deaths
thank you
so stoked
mr speaker in terms of the the latter
part of her question the national
clinical audit if she may i'll write her
about that only her important point
about boards uh she is right the the
report does this final report does talk
about the importance of boards and
properly making sure that the people on
the boards are vetted but also they
understand their responsibilities and
have the information that they need to
carry out their responsibilities and
also it's my understanding i think in
2014 or thereabouts the cqc also changed
the rules around board members for nhs
trust requiring them to meet a new fit
and proper test
thank you mr speaker it is impossible to
think about uh these lost babies lost
lives uh and damaged families without
getting really upset and they're very
very angry but the work i've been doing
with midwives
and families moms and dads um in the
last six months or so shows me that this
is not just one trust we had thousands
of midwives marching on the streets we
had the pandemic where mums uh were
taken to social media feeling really
marginalized and their voices not heard
uh but midwives are telling me they
haven't wanted to speak out before
because they don't want to frighten the
mums and dads in their charge and and
that's why they often feel that they're
not heard themselves so
how how is we've so we've got to help
them because how is the nhs and the
government going to reassure pregnant
women and help the midwives reassure
pregnant women given all of this in the
news at the moment and how can we
prevent other maternity services failing
so
mr speaker my honorable friend raised a
very important point that there are
hundreds of thousands of births in the
nhs you deliver through the nhs each
year and the vast vast vast majority of
them are completely
safe as i found for myself and many
honourable members in this house
including my normal friend but what
we've heard about today is when it goes
wrong and goes tragically wrong but
especially when it was avoidable that's
the point when it was avoidable and
she's right to talk about the importance
of
of other trusts in this this is focused
on one trust but we know already
that there was a problem in walking bay
we know there's an investigation going
on in east kent at the moment as well an
independent investigation and so this is
there's action for all trust and that's
why i think it's very important uh that
the nhs acts on the recommendations for
the wider nhs and i act on the
recommendations for the white department
and we will certainly be doing that and
so will the nhs carla lockhart
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
secretary of state for his statement not
one person could help but be moved by
the account and by his sincerity and
dealing with this horrific situation i
also want to commend all uh involved in
the occurrend report
for their work on this issue
our hearts break for the little babies
the moms the dads and the family units
who have been impacted by these
horrendous practices and today we
remember and commend the bravery of the
families of those who have the courage
to speak out given the findings and the
negative cloud that will be over
uh all of those who work in maternity
services will executive state take this
opportunity to thank those maternity
teams right throughout this
united kingdom who day and daily bring
new life
into this world in a compassionate and
professional manner i think of the
wonderful services in my own
constituency of upper ban
area hospital and i know today
they will be saddened by what they're
hearing uh in terms of this report so i
trust that you can commend them for the
work
so i i will warmly join the honourable
lady in in in thanking and commending
the work of maternity teams you
throughout
the united kingdom what they do day in
day out especially over the last two
years with the pandemic probably making
it
even even harder
than than normal and and i know that
many of those uh working with tecna will
i indeed all of them will welcome this
report because they will want to see the
very changes that are set out in this
report jill morton
thank you mr speaker
i'd also like to thank the families for
shining a spotlight on this
one of my children suffered from oxygen
deprivation at birth from what i now
know of failings in my care
i was lucky though my third pregnancy
shear flu the gp practice i was
registered with had a wonderful
community midwife she was with me
through my pregnancy she was with me at
my the birth of my daughter and she took
care of me afterwards
i was listened to i was supported and i
felt safe
whilst i thank my right honourable
friend for taking on board these
recommendations would he agree with me
that every woman deserves that
continuity of care and that can make a
profound difference in outcomes for
families
they will have somebody by their side
who understands them they won't have to
go through their medical history over
and over again
often you know missing out vital pieces
we should have loftier ambitions will my
right honourable friend try and make it
that every woman will have that
opportunity to have their own midwife
with them all the way
yes sir i agree very much with my
honorable friend can i thank her for for
sharing with her house her own valuable
experiences but she's right to talk
about the importance of continuity of
care that is part of our maternity
transformation plan
welcome
thank you very much mr speaker
thank the secretary of state for the
report and it's with sadness that we
have to have a report such as this in
front of the house but in doing so
uh i want to maybe highlight a point in
relation to and check that we can do
something about it those who within the
system and there are many good people
working within our nhs
unfortunately probably the majority of
people are there for the right reasons
but unfortunately
due to a process or a culture of
institutional blindness has been
mentioned earlier
or bullying
they cannot whistle blow and whistle
blowers are not being protected and as a
consequence more and more of these types
of reports are going to be required not
maybe to do with maternity services but
other services because whistleblowers
are being targeted and put down i would
ask that the whistleblowers be protected
and given the opportunity to have their
concerns
understood and heard thursday
the the honourable gentleman mr speaker
is absolutely right and one of the
reasons we are creating the special
health authority that referred to
earlier is to provide that independence
and also more protection for members of
staff to come forward and members of
staff for example for the first time
will be able to report
things that they're concerned about
directly to the ss sha and they will
have the right to investigate
pay jones thank you mr speaker many
members uh from across the house have
mentioned the incredible gravy of all of
the parents who fought for their babies
particularly rhiannon davis um rhiannon
is originally from mid wales although
she now lives in honourable members
constituencies across the border but
there are many women who live in mid
wales who need to access showsbury and
telford hospital and i am concerned that
they will be hearing today's report and
will be worried about their care that
they might be receiving over the next
few days so as well as implementing the
ocandon review in full with the
secretary of state please give his
reassurance to those women in wales who
need to travel across the border for
maternity services
service state
yes i can give that uh reassurance and
uh i can also add that i know that donna
okada in her doing her work she looked
at cases uh from wales as well and and
the issues he's raised for me also has
been raised by our honorable friend and
then for montgomery show and i can give
them both their shorts
jim shelton thank you mr speaker can i
first of all thank the secretary of
state for his statement and for his very
obvious compassion that he has for all
those involved in his and his support of
the auckland report
first may i piss and record mr deputy
speaker my sympathy to all of those
parents who still grieve their loss and
to whom no report will ever ever sue the
pain
will the city of state confirm that the
report into this dreadful speed of death
will be made available to all hospital
trusts across the united kingdom
including northern ireland to ensure
that lessons learned
on the 84 recommendations of the
auckland report and any mechanisms or
prevention can be understood and put in
place
uk wide thank you steve
yes mr speaker i can give the honourable
gentleman that assurance that it indeed
with the northern ireland health service
for instance uh we we're more than happy
and to reach out and to work proactively
with them in in improving maternity
services in northern ireland too so i'm
a bench thank you mr speaker i'd like to
thank my right honourable friend for his
statement well the health center sanji
java they're giving his reaction to this
report uh by donna ockendon and to
maternity provision at shrewsbury and
telford nhs trust some 201 babies nine
mothers
could have survived if their trust had
provided better care
the health minister providing an apology
i am sorry you were failed by services
we will make changes he promises and he
pointed out that a number of people have
been suspended or struck off
as a result of that
let's bring in beth heath who is head of
clinical negligence at lanyon bowder now
this is the firm currently
with a hundred live claims against
shrewsbury and telford hospital nhs
trust and uh the health secretary did
point out that there are going to be
some legal cases now following this so
we we don't want to say anything that is
going to jeopardize those but um in
terms of your experience that you've had
dealing with this trust up to now
what kind of reaction did you get from
the trust when you were
first approaching them with these
complaints and issues that people
clearly had
it's been a little bit of a mixed bag in
terms of the responses from the trust
and unfortunately where we consider
those strong uh clinical negligence
cases admissions aren't always
forthcoming from the trust which is
extremely disappointing and obviously
distressing for families as well
so why what is it behind what we've
heard today it seems that there was a
sort of um obsession with natural births
at this trust which natural births are
obviously great for some
moms who who are able to have them and
who want them and who are very low-risk
pregnancies but it it's certainly not a
prescribed thing that is is right for
all mums is it
no absolutely not
and each um individual woman needs to be
assessed um as an individual
and
unfortunately the trust for many many
years have had a relentless pursuit
of a natural delivery and at times that
has been a detriment to the woman and
their their child and i have numerous
cases where women say they were either
ignored when they were requested as
their inception or their requests were
repeatedly denied and um there'll be
times when there perhaps there were
delays in reverting to a cesarean
section when a child was in just stress
so that the baby was in distress and
there were delays in delivering that
child again which
in very the worst case such situations
can cause hypoxic brain damage
so where do you think this culture came
from
it's very difficult to to say and
obviously it's very deep rooted and it's
been a culture at that trust for a long
long time
i know that there's there's problems
between the midwives and the
obstetricians in terms of um a lack of
collaborative working
with um it very much being like a uh
them in our culture which donald orchard
does before refer to in her report and i
think that lack of um collaborative
working is quite instrumental because it
means that
the midwives don't escalate
appropriately to senior clinicians when
um perhaps they have a high risk
pregnancy or a woman is in distress
and the baby is in distress sorry but
also and when they do escalate the
concerns there's complete lack of
attendance from obstetricians or delays
and attendance
so they're really just not working as a
team and it's a detriment to the women
and the safety of their unborn child
and what's very clear is that women's
voices weren't being heard at this
hospital at this trust
is it because they're women do you
well as think
woman myself i'd certainly hope not um i
think what should be happening is women
should be empowered to make decisions
about their own care and how they
deliver their baby they should be given
the risks and the benefits of each of
the options and then it should be their
decision to make how they deliver their
child
unfortunately that hasn't been happening
and i think
um women haven't been empowered like
they should have done or given a voice
like they should have done and that's
something that definitely needs to to
change and i think the
the whole um
cesarean section issue has been a big a
big player in that in that regard
i mean you know you say women should
feel empowered to make a choice but but
so often and not it isn't a choice is it
it's
it
you might have whatever birth plan you
you want and you know you might want
cows moving and a birthing pool but in
reality your body will will do what your
body will do and
it's that's the point isn't it that you
then need
an expert you then need somebody to
to understand what is going on to say
no you can't do it this way you have to
do it this way for the safety of the
baby and are you suggesting that that
just weren't the people there making
that proper decision
i think there's definitely a lack of
senior clinicians on hand um giving that
advice to women and which obviously um
midwives need to have the support of the
obstetricians and they're the ones with
the expertise when it comes to the
higher risk cases and i just don't think
the women were getting that that advice
to be able to make those decisions and
even if the body yes the body is
constantly changing and um
labor and delivery is very much um
you have to adapt and but women should
still be able to make a decision about
how they deliver even when things are
rapidly changing
and briefly given your dealings with the
trust do you have any hope that things
will change as a result of this report
i'm hopeful um and i really hope that
the trust do make changes um i think
there's still an element of
me feeling a little bit skeptical and
there have been loads of really good
recommendations made to the trust over
the years that haven't been implemented
and there's been countless missed
opportunities for change over the years
and unfortunately i am still seeing um
cases coming through from 2020 and 2021
with um
the the themes that have been prevalent
um for a number of years at this trust
um
but the recommendations are there
there's 60 recommendations for um the
trust and they have the framework um in
which to do it so i really hope that
they do do it just so that the women
in our local community um feel safe
delivering care and don't go out of
barrier which a lot of them are doing at
the moment and um they are
kind of they feel safe that they're
going to get the best possible care at
their local hospital
yeah well you can but hope beth heath um
from lanyon bowdler this is the shrubby
base law firm that's been dealing with a
lot of these cases
thank you very much for joining us
thank you
a bit of breaking news this lunch time
the parole board has now approved the
release from prison of tracy connolly
she is the mother of baby p who died in
2007 after suffering more than 50
injuries sky's sadia chowdhury joins us
from the newsroom sadia this was a case
which really shocked the nation but the
fact remains that this uh woman has
served her time hasn't she yes she's
serving prison right now for the
for causing or